pa, pa, pa (where's the LASERs..... ok its not PEW NEWS)
It's time for me to flex on you kids just a little bit, don't worry.
I got this new LG Wallpaper TV.
It's seriously the coolest TV I've ever have.
And I wanna show it off to you, guys.
As you can see, perfect pictures, perfect quality. It's like--it's like looking through a window. It genuinely feels like it.
So, as you can see, when it gets black, it's actually black. Which is, uh, OLED technology, that's right, Google it.
So cool. (very nice)
You don't get that in a lot of TVs, also, the way it's so thin, look how thin it is. It's like actually having a picture on your wallet, like I've never seen anything like it. THIN LIKE MY DEPRESSION
It's so cool.
Like look at that, how is it even real?
So, all the hardware is in the soundbar, which has amazing theater-like audio as well.
So it's got the perfect theater video and audio experience with Dolby Vision and Dolby Atmos.
So it really feels like a movie theater.
Wait, I wanna show this. Look at that. WoHahA.
It's a window, everybody! You don't need windows anymore. Just get an LG Wallpaper TV.
I don't know how to best describe it, but it's genuinely unlike anything I've seen.
Thankyou LG for sponsoring this video. If you guys wanna check out one as well, link is in the description. And, let's get back to the video. (GOD THANK YOU)
Guys, this is extremely serious
Memes is about to get banned
in the EU
This might be the last
LWIAY
We have ever done
and I'm going to savor it
to its very little piece of meme
Welcome to the final episode
of LWIAY
I know. I know it's tough
I know it's tough, but we must get through this
Honestly, I'm, kind of, like
I know everyone is like
"Oh, no, let's not ban memes."
50% of me says YAS OKURRRR
There's a small part of me that unironically thinks "You know what
just let them dieeee
JUST LET EM DIE
You look at memes like the Boar Etruscan
500 - 600 BC
And you just have to think for yourself (oh really i thought someone will do it for me pewds)
Just let it die. Let--just burn it all down
Let's just burn it all down
But anyway,  let's begin reviewing the memes
If you understand this, you're going to hell
wtf
Damn it.
When you studied 4 years of journalism and you end up writing for BuzzFeed
Yeah. Who doesn't like to be $25,000 in debt and took a career path that can't really be adapted too much else?
What do you call a sad strawberry?
A blueberry
Jesus. F, man.
F outta here with your retarded puns
Listen here, you huge sack of shit
You're being berry rude
*meme review*
I'm trying to kill the meme
Not working
It's too strong
World War 3 will be Battle Royal
It just makes sense
But is it going to be Trump's take on Battle Royal?
Is it going to be a politically correct Battle Royal?
A progressive thinking Battle Royale?
Hmm?
Sharing the memes I made with friends in the EU said that I don't get in trouble
Wouldn't it be awesome if memes just becomes this underground illegal business?
I mean, I guess it already is
And that's the point
You know what, we live in the darkest, most terrible timeline
Upvote if you want Gloria Borger and Poppy Harlow to host Pew News together
Now you're just being greedy, okay?
Poppy would never sink so low
8K = All hell can be seen on face
Wow. I look exactly like my dad
It's terrifying
4K = Can see sadness beyond expression
720p = Looks pretty fine
360p = Happiest goddamn motherf*cker
We need to reduce the quality, okay?
You can see my depression
And it's not pretty
Moving on
Oh, man. Why do people--if I needed to take a break, I would take a break
I appreciate the nice comments
But no
No.
Poor Poppy
Poppy Harlow, according to Wikipedia, is a Swedish--an Swedish news anchor
best known for being the anchor at the world's most reliable news source
Pew News
Thank you, Wikipedia, for delivering accurate information once again.
Chris Frog right there
Chris Frog and I are playing Box of Lies after the break
Stick around, everybody
Oh, man
Fake. It's fake, okay?
It's not cringey, but it's fake
Don't waste my time with this
9-year olds = I miss Fridays with Pewdiepie
Me, an intellectual = I miss Pewdiepie roasting Jacksepticktank in pretty much every video
Damn it.
What happened?
Well, I guess he died
Where girls cried, where boys cried, where 9-year-olds cried
Awwww. That is so sweet
You're all a bunch of dummies
Goodbye, Gloria Borger, and welcome, Poppy Harlow, with new unlocked characters
Slippy gets a comeback. That's nice. That's pretty cool. Thank you.
Imagine a conversation between these two people.
Just give me another--a couple more years on YouTube
I'll, I'll end up like those coo-coos
Pewdiepie is not actually quitting, he's just teasing the release of Pewdiepie 2
Damn it.
No, no, no, this is not true
Meme correction. There it is, everyone.
Why don't you use the one where my f*****g hair is brown?
Why do you keep using that picture?
Meme correction again. Do it right.
Can we copystrike the Vikings?
Really?
We're still--we're still doing this?
Six months later, we,we get Ugandan Knuckles memes
Fantastic
You know, maybe if Black Panther came out recently, I would be like "Oh, that's funny."
Jesus Christ, dude.
Bring back "Please don't Tell Marzia Productions."
That would involve us actually going outside and filming
Uh, I think not.
Jesus Christ, this is the reason I didn't post anything on twitter when it happened
Cuz a lot of it seems like
Hey
I found out this person died
And now I'm wanna tell you
Just telling rest in peace I er- I remember Whitney Houston died
So many people in my feed were like "Rest in Peace Whitney Houston."
I'm like "You don't give a fuck about Whitney Houston."
*Laughs* Wait Whitney Houston is dead?
Did you now that Whitney Houston's debut LP..
Had 4 number one singles on it?
Did'ya know that? CHRISTIE??
"I FRICKIN EDITED THAT ON WIKIPEDIA AND SOMEONE SCREENSHOTTED IT AND PUT IT ON REDDIT AND GOT 1K UPVOTES"
*Silent Laughing*
*B R E A T H I N*
"THIS IS BULLCRAP"
*Stock laughter in the background* I've never so been proud of you nine year olds
NEVER BEEN SO PROUD! (Thank you Pewdie I'm honoured)
WELL DONE! *Fist in air* Yeah!